[Music]
it's almost midnight on Valentine's Day
if you're watching this there's a good
chance you're home alone without a
Valentine that's but there's still time
to snag that special someone come on
down to the pickup line warehouse we've
got thousands of unused pickup lines
available at rock-bottom prices
lines like you must be yogurt because I
want to spoon you hey do you not know
the proper way to use cigarettes because
that ass is smoking is your last name
Whitman because I want to sample you are
you the lottery lady on TV because I'm
picturing you holding up my balls
peanut butter your jelly let's have sex
no I really feel sorry for blind people
I'd like to connect with you on Boynton
network is it hot in here or are your
boobs just huge are some of these
terrible of course they are that's why
they're unused but at this hour it's
time to throw everything against the
wall and see what sticks we've got boxes
and boxes of unused pickup lines just
waiting to help you all sales final no
returns or refunds not responsible for
slapping sneeze at the growing drinks
thrown in your face or legal fallout
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]